est-ce que vous croyez qu'on peut faire
l'amour 4 fois de suite que toi tu dans
la
vie dans la vie
c'est qu'on bouge pas dans le jingle oui
je sais d'ailleurs à chaque fois que je
vois l'émission Laurent Baffie
il y a un mouvement qui s'est créé
[Musique]
de toute façon je bouge pas beaucoup
permanent effectivement vous avez raison
regarde bien alors Gad Elmaleh on se
concentre si l'interview croyance ok ok
est-ce que vous croyez que la religion
juive et la meilleure non
est-ce que vous croyez que le peuple
juif et le peuple élu
c'est ce qui a écrit dans les textes
mais j'ai pas le droit de vote donc je
suis un peu dans la c'est vrai vous avez
pas le droit de vote vous payez les
impôts vous avez pas le droit de vote
vous êtes que deux passeports pour le
moment non je oui enfin je suis marocain
mais en tant que c'est pour les Français
je suis Canadien quoi c'est à dire que
quand je suis arrivé j'ai demandé mes
papiers je les ai demandé en tant
qu'anadien je les ai pas demandé en tant
que marocain voilà est-ce que vous
croyez en Dieu oui
est-ce que vous croyez en vous oui oui
est-ce que vous croyez au pouvoir
magique de Goldorak
[Rires]
oui sinon je serai pas là ce soir ça
c'est clair est-ce que vous croyez que
le PSG peut remonter
oui oui parce que
ah bon ah
pour le
m il y en a deux vous êtes deux pour
l'OM ce soir
pourquoi Caroline vous êtes pour l'OM
parce que
longtemps à Marseille et que quand on
vient à Marseille
[Musique]
est-ce que vous croyez que Lionel Jospin
va être présent dans la République
j'aimerais bien
encore une fois
j'aimerais lui dire
l'homme politique qui a pas de cravate
vous croyez qu'il va être présent dans
la République non je pense pas du tout
du mal dans le bus
il a déjà baissé
au niveau des vêtements il fait des
efforts
voyez qu'on peut faire l'amour 4 fois de
suite 4 fois de suite dans la
vie
dans la vie non dans la dans la dans la
vraie vie ouais bien sûr
mais elle a de la chance
vous croyez à l'amour toujours non
tu voudrais un break après
est-ce que vous croyez qu'il faut faire
l'amour le samedi soir devant tout le
monde en parle sans bouger pendant le
jingle
car s'il pleut le dimanche vous serez
plus quoi faire
c'est Jacqueline et Philippe Dumont qui
m'ont envoyé cette blague et je la
trouve bien c'est mieux qu'une blague
d'ailleurs
il y a 25 ans
qui vont me dire la semaine prochaine
Gad Elmaleh il a un regard formidable
qui m'a demandé votre numéro de portable
et tout et ben écoutez
j'ai appris ça ouais
si quelqu'un cherche une brune à forte
poitrine la dernière fois que j'ai vu
l'émission il y avait une fille sublime
ouais Aurélie Dupont Aurélie Dupont la
danseuse
incroyable est-ce que vous croyez que
cette interview est terminée non
j'espère pas faute et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu